parlons chiffon maintenant chiffon hop
et aux cravates puisque la mode comme on
peut le constater en ce moment au salon
international de belles l'habillement
masculin à paris la mode se conjugue
aussi au masculin
les hommes sont de plus en plus coquets
la consommation de vêtements masculins
augmente
et pourtant l'industrie française de la
vie mans va mal pour la première fois
elle est en déficit
à cause des importations qui croise
encore plus vite pour illustrer les
tendances de cet hiver messieurs france
rend chez christian giroux ont découvert
deux superbes créatures dont vous
devinerez le sexe
au salon de l'habillement masculin entre
quelques milliers d'acheteurs et
quelques millions de vêtements
voici le plus beau produit de la mode la
belle 80,2 carlos miranda à m 83 73 kg
bill portugais ni canadien bel animal mi
ange mi félin il y en a un autre tout
pareil rugiero son jumeau tous les deux
mannequins ils vous ferait prendre un
sac de pommes de terre pour un smoking
9ème à paris aujourd'hui à milan demain
avec leurs petits camarades également
favorisé question physique
nous leur chic et leur beauté aux
créateurs de mode
ces deux blazer de guy laroche le bleu
pour le sport le havane pour la ville
sont très bien mais sur les me randall
deviennent irrésistibles c'est une
question de métier métier difficile du
style plein d'embûches
de quoi souffre ton le plus dans le
milieu des baux minet
la ville d'eysines s quand il ya
beaucoup de compétition tout le monde
est beau dans un sens sont pas tous
pareils
alors si quelqu'un réussit à voir le
boulot et l'autre et les chewing reçu
par ses écrits une ambiance très
agréable
qu'est ce que vous faites pour
vous entretenir du sport du régime
surtout du sport j'habitais alors dit
moi ce que je puis me permettre de
perdre deux ports parti lundi soir
aulas
ce genre comme ça et soins de beauté il
a 21 ans ça viendra plus tard par la
forme il faut aussi avoir un book c'est
à dire ce gros album montrant le cover
boy sous des aspects aussi variés que
possible grâce à quoi il sera engagé
pour faire des photos 3000 francs pour
deux heures de pause
ici par exemple sous la supervision du
patron daniel hechter carlos pause
empêcheurs de charme avec poche dorsale
pour poissons et casquette assortie aux
yeux le préférez vous en lilas pour
safari photo avec bandes molletières
écharpe kaki un résident toujours riche
terre et c'est ainsi qu'on se retrouve
sur des affiches ou des posters voici
ruggiero version pdg énergique mais
rêveur mais quelles qualités faut-il
posséder avant tout la face uras
raisonnable des lettrés les listes que
c'est du rap à gontaud rang et il faut
savoir garder les utilisateurs
il faut de la patience en effet pour ce
faire toiser examiné déshabiller par les
acheteurs ou les journalistes dans les
showrooms ici un impair kaki cours d'un
amaury de la patience pour transpirer
par 40 degrés sous les projecteurs d'un
stand une parka bordeaux de structures
de la patience enfin pour attendre quand
on a été convoqué la réponse qui amènera
un appel de l' agence qui s'occupe de 82
garçons de plus de 100 fille pour des
contrats de 2001 dix mille francs dont
le mannequin garde 37%
le plaisir c'est de défilé cette année
l'homme se portera mad max descendu de
la guerre des étoiles
un rien aventuriers avec des colliers de
chefs de tribus
françois girbaud il sera très coloré
voyous me coquet campeurs en rolls
sportif à la peau douce et capitaine
pour mr pastel façonnable et marcel la
sens
il sera effectué ici par lucien fond
celle de dignité candide et de lin blanc
matière à la mode et la récompense c'est
de saluer à la fin du show avec creap